all right so quick one um i'll give you
my very sexy headline how i turned 1036
dollars into 112 million
496 422 in revenue in over 44 months
using four unique acquisition frameworks
would you guys want to know what those
are okay cool quick writer downer does
everyone here own their own legion and
you know how to generate your own leads
everyone does no okay someone doesn't so
i'm going to give you four steps really
quickly before i even get into this
presentation because this is i would say
these are frameworks that you can
immediately use and
um with the presentation that was given
just uh mr burton about how to capture
leads and whatnot you're gonna need
traffic right and so i'm gonna show you
the things that we've used uh very very
successfully to get more traffic
but before you do that this is something
that you can do in less than 15 minutes
and pretty much solve your lead gen
problem uh right now you can google
number one you can put it to somebody in
your company how to run a facebook lead
ad
probably seven minutes number two how to
connect facebook lead ad to google
sheets via zapier number three
give away something free
and then target the audience that you
want
if you don't know how to target the
audience that you want
take your existing customer list google
how to set up a facebook lookalike
audience and then run it to that
audience that's it
like yeah
google number one
how to run a facebook lead ad google
number two
how to connect facebook lead ads to
google sheets with zapier
z-a-p-i-e-r number three
you're going to target your either local
audience or whatever audience it is that
you use if it's not local then you'll
upload a customer list if you don't know
how to do that that would be video
number four which is how to create a
look like audience on facebook
and then number five give them something
for free in exchange for their phone
number that's it
you can get leads you're welcome it'll
take you 60 minutes and this by the way
is what every third-party legion company
is doing and they charge you five times
more for that process they also pay
someone and just from a belief
standpoint
every single i know all the guys in that
space the guy's pushing the buttons they
train in less than seven days
with
two hours of videos and they're paid
under 15 bucks an hour this is not hard
stuff people just don't know how to do
it and now it's very easy and it's all
on youtube cool because that's the
that's like the really button clicky
stuff i wasn't going to stand up here
and be like all right
connect here and i think that'd be a
waste everyone's time so this is going
to be the stuff that's going to make the
return on that significantly higher is
that cool
all right awesome yeah 112 million that
was cool all right so um
using the four frameworks we're able to
double down again and again so that
literally was my bank account and over
the next 44 months we're room will spend
3.1 million in advertising um
which gives us a 36-1 lifetime return on
advertising um so i don't know what your
return on advertising are um but i'm
told that's pretty good and so i'll just
share stuff that worked well for us
okay so that's me co-founder my
beautiful wife who's up here being
awesome and dealing with me but that was
me when i started albert you and i have
very similar stories slept on the floor
i had no idea what i was doing went to a
facebook marketing event literally the
week before my gym opened and was like
oh so this is how i'll get customers and
i was able to actually fill my gym up
using that stuff in 2013 and so i was
able to scale from zero to six locations
in under three years as a kid
off cash flow which is pretty neat
and then i sold all of those
and uh lost everything and that's where
my bank account was at the end because
the guy that i got into business with
was indicted for fraud um and so i had
that entire process and then i had
nothing again i screenshotted it because
i was like i know i'm going to tell the
story so um from there because i still
was good at running gyms uh we started
gym launch my wife and i
we went from zero dollars when i took
that picture to 2.4 million a month in
18 months
we ran 74 net margins on that business
very good business
um prestige labs went from zero 1.7 in
six months the reason i'm telling you
the speed on these is because the
acquisition stuff i'm gonna share with
you all right allen which is went from
zero to one point four in six months
this is actually my most reconnected
recent acquisition we went from 40k to
700 000 a month in 10 months um and so
just so you have an idea in terms of
different spaces that's b2b licensing
this is ecommerce direct to direct to
consumer this is agency software um and
then this one is a brick and mortar
chain of childhood
magical experiences the thing is you
should see the numbers behind this thing
anyhoo so this is what we do now take
interest in seven eight multi figure
businesses and grow the eggs in three to
five years that's what we do the reason
that uh this presentation is so cool for
me is that i don't usually get to talk
about this stuff so i'm pumped about it
but what was really cool was during that
process we've made over a thousand
success stories like a lot like a lot of
success stories um using the framework
i'm gonna show you create 71
millionaires and counting so very happy
about that and so i just want to take
you through this the frameworks that we
use to scale our companies and this is
what we do when we're scaling companies
it's the same checklist every time this
is what i look at
so this should be right for everyone
who's either under 100 dollars a month
this should help you establish your
first reliable acquisition channel what
i said in the very beginning that's the
tactics google those five videos you'll
have lead gen that's that all right but
i'll show you how to do it and make way
more money from it the second is if
you're over a hundred thousand dollars a
month how to get your next acquisition
channel profitable so you can get your
current acquisition to your next
acquisition brian asked me to give you
some really tactical [ __ ] they can use
uh so the four frameworks uh my goal is
not to break beliefs or tell stories or
motivate anyone i'm going to say the
stuff that's like working right now so
uh mental rewind was totally a business
game of golden bbs and not silver
bullets so today my goal is to give you
as many golden bbs as possible very
candidly there's going to be a lot of
things you're going to think about this
like a checklist all right you're going
to have a hole here there's a pocket of
money here a pocket of money here and i
just want you to scoop up as many of the
ones that make sense to you some of them
you already have some of you maybe not
but you'll have by the end of the
presentation i guarantee you'll have a
lot of ways to make more so quick
groundwork this is the first thing we do
so only two ways to grow a business that
is it i start from the top and then
we'll break it down from there all right
number one is you get more customers
seems obvious right this is where
everyone looks number two make customers
worth more there's no other way that's
it get more make them worth more and
sometimes simplicity is the ultimate in
elegance i think coco chanel said that
or aristotle
either way it's so cool but since
everyone here probably is trying to grow
your business that's all we're going to
be talking about so four frameworks one
get more customers two make more money
framework number one the math which is
going to be how to acquire customers as
a profit who here has a marketing budget
you have a marketing budget i will show
you how to get rid of that shouldn't
have one because if you can spend to
acquire customers at a profit as in they
are net cash flow positive it means i
make money before i even have my credit
card due which means it eliminates a
acquisition as a bottleneck in your
business and b if you don't have capital
like you saw my bank account at the
beginning of this thing
you can compete against anyone still if
you have the skill like this is real
like you can still crush it right now
against people who have way more money
because they don't know the game right
the game that's happening under
everyone's nose so that's the math all
right we call that customer client
finance acquisition number two is the
offer so how to get complete strangers
to raise their hands and make offers so
good they'd feel stupid saying no all
right so i'll show you how like kind of
how i said that little ad that's going
to break down what we do there number
three is of the traffic so once you have
those two things in place you know what
math you need to hit you know what
you're going to give them then we got to
go find traffic all right so i'll give
you the six traffic sources that exist
right now that everyone has access to
and my hope is that you'll probably find
two or three traffic sources that are in
front of you i've got a special page for
brad in there so you can look out for
that your team can look out for that
sorry i'm gonna give you guys homework
and then the fourth one
is the money right so the whole point
here is to make money and i'll show you
exactly how we maximize back back end
ltv which informs the front end which is
why ultimately it's much more of a
circle than it is steps so that makes
sense we have the math we make our offer
go to the traffic we make money which
means we update our math and around and
around we go all right that's the game
plan cool yeah all right rock and roll
so if you like childhood pictures this
is what i like to draw so you see a lot
of doodles in this presentation this is
the simple way of seeing it so you got
math traffic offer update and then you
got the money that you're reeling it in
okay quite literally so we're going to
start with the math there we go
client finance acquisition how to
require customers out of profit this is
the entire process mapped out
don't worry you'll i'll break down each
of these steps but this is what it is
all right so this is i'm going to show
you how to make money with no money
which means if you have money you'll be
able to do far better than this this is
how you do it if you have zero dollars
in your bank account right now so if you
have less money than your competition or
feel like you need to spend or you're
spending too much to require customers
this is for you this is how you do it so
quick definitions real quick cost you
require a customer because sometimes i
say these quickly and i forget who i'm
talking to so cost required customer i
say cac all right all costs um required
to acquire a new customer advertising
payroll media buyer creative team
software all that stuff is cost required
customer number two cost of goods sold
direct cost of fulfillment gross profits
the amount of money that is left over
after the direct cost of fulfilling so
if you had one more customer how much
action would you have to pay to fulfill
that everything after that is the juice
right gross profit payback period the
time of period it takes the business to
receive the gross profit necessary that
it cost them to acquire the customer
back right you put a dollar in you get a
customer you know tomorrow and then it
takes you two months for before you get
that cash back in your wallet to spend
again all right those are cash
conversion cycles i'm going to show you
how we do this quickly the more you can
condense the cash conversion cycle the
faster you can grow all right especially
if you don't have funding which i've
never had all right and then 30-day cash
is something that
that's not that i invented it's just
something that we track which is the
amount of gross profit that i can
extract from a new customer in the first
30 days the reason i track this so
vehemently is that like many business
owners here
everyone has access to one thing which
is a credit card and so
i basically know that i i have 30 days
against the clock that i can spend
whatever i want and as long as i have it
back plus some in 30 days i never have
to use my own money to grow
so i have all the financing i need and i
can grow for free
and essentially get my customers to pay
for the growth of my business okay so
doesn't worry this is the only math
equation the entire thing this equation
is what has created everything in my
life your 30-day cash so this is the
plain english of this i have to generate
more cash in the first 30 days of
running an advertisement than it costs
me to acquire two customers and the cost
to fulfill both of them cost of
acquiring customer and the cost of
fulfilling them times two if i can make
more than that in the first 30 days off
of one customer
i can grow unlimited that's how we went
from zero to two million zero to two
million zero to whatever in six months
eight months ten months because it
really becomes operational drag not
about the acquisition so um and it's a
positive cash flow so that entire
process while you're growing we're
taking cash out every single month while
we're growing it's cool cool to
experience
um and so this allows all of us smaller
players who are not bc backed to
outspend everyone okay so this is a
quick walkthrough i'm drilling this one
in because it's really important to
understand this concept works so you
borrow a hundred dollars from a credit
card to a park two customers at fifty
dollars each this is a hypothetical
two of those customers each spend three
hundred dollars with you so you make six
hundred bucks now you're up but you
still have to fill the customer so cost
you fifty dollars each 100 total at the
end you have four hundred dollars plus
you have two new customers and you can
continue to sell those and you have 400
in your bank account what this looks
like visually
this is how you generate buckets of cash
yes all right this is what it looks like
visually i'm a big visual guy so zero
debt zero money zero customers day zero
all right from there we take our little
debt there we go
100 and we spend 100 bucks in ads we do
exactly what i said in the beginning
you're going to get your you're going to
run your little ads and you're going to
get your opt-ins
there we go so they're going to run the
ads in front of eyeballs eyeballs are
going to get clicks which burton's going
to track for us right we're going to get
opt-ins we're going to schedule them
we're going to they're going show and
then we're gonna get sales and there's
two of those people so it's visually
what i just said i'm just depicting it
for you all right and now we have to
fill fulfill those people so 600 goes to
500 500 goes to 400 400 goes to my bank
account and after the dust settles
this is what happens good suspense
though right
when the dust settles there i am debt
free
i have 400 in cash
and i have two customers that i can now
sell whatever the [ __ ] i want for frey
that's the game you can add zero
subtract zeros but this is what we're
doing all right so you have to
understand the math before we get into
the stuff this is when i doubled down so
then you double it down again you do the
whole process boom 800 400 goes to
fulfillment it's literally just going
black on vegas in vegas again and then
that was our first round and our second
round we doubled the amount of customers
the third round we quadruple the amount
of customers and a round and round we go
if you can execute client finance
acquisition until your operations break
this will therefore eliminate the need
for capital to constrain on your growth
i think this is a big deal
just like cool i just want to make sure
i'm like tracking them okay cool so
that's number one the math how to
acquire customers as a profit client
finance acquisition and there's my
little arrow and my check mark it's been
a long time making here the check marks
work okay
the offer how to make offer so good
people feel stupid saying no that's the
little wormy guy right here got to get
the fishies to bite great slime offers
how to make off so good people stupid
saying no so the problem so right now
the first one i said is right now if you
spend too much money to our customers or
you have a marketing budget or any of
those types of things that's your
problem if you don't have that problem
this might be your problem if your ads
aren't converting well all right clicks
versus opt-ins like you're like i feel
like we're spending but we're not
getting [ __ ] right
or your sales team has trouble scaling
like it's hard to ramp up new guys um
they're having trouble closing all that
kind of stuff obviously the sales part
you've already got covered but a lot of
times it's the offer so i just actually
had a consulting day yesterday we
rewrote the entire offer and i'll give
you a couple cool examples that i've
done with the companies that i've worked
with so to catch fish you need bait for
an offer the starting point of any
conversation to initiate a transaction
with a customer what you are literally
providing to them in exchange for their
money usually with marketing campaigns
it's going to be the number one driver
of success what does it do if you do
this properly it'll allow you to sell in
a vacuum so you don't have price
shopping or any of that stuff all right
it creates a category of when it forces
customers to make a values-based
decision instead of a price-based
decision lately and i sell days of our
time for
a hundred grand
and
like that doesn't make any sense because
there's plenty of marketing firms who do
a full day for free or a thousand
dollars but because it's incomparable
they'll do that all right people will
pay it
so
the goal is to decommoditize the offer
and if we do this properly we'll
increase our click-through rates our
ctrs which means
of the eyeballs that see it more people
to say decide to take one step towards
us of the people who take a step towards
us more of them think it's interesting
and decide to opt in
and then not only that once they're on
the phone with us because the offer is
so compelling more of them say yes and
so this is a multiplicative effect and
so the translation is more leads more
sales higher prices so here's uh two
real life examples so when i had my my
little gym i struggled to sell a 99 a
month boot camp
like i could not i couldn't even close
people on a free trial it was sad i
switched from a 99 a month boot camp to
a free six-week challenge
and the way that we structured the offer
was people would come in
they would put 600 down they lost 20
pounds i'd give them the money back
but
48 hours after they bought we sell them
300 supplements 21 days after that we'd
say hey you want to just win the
challenge right now and stay on as a
member we'll give you the 600 back as
credit towards a membership you want to
do that we close 70 to 80 of people on
that and so if you follow the money it
was just 600 300
12 year 12 month contract my cost of
acquisition dropped by
a tenth
and um we would get 30 to one up front
before our membership dues
so the reason i was able to open six
gyms in three years as a 23-year-old who
didn't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] was because
i was making so much money in the first
30 days i could open a gym sign a lease
and have it completely full on someone
else's money before the first client
showed up and i had all the payroll
staffed and paid for for the next six
weeks before the eft kicked in eft is
the recurring revenue [ __ ] all right and
so it was simply by changing the offer i
was i was still using the same platforms
i was still the same salesman right but
it was changing the offer so many more
people clicked so many people more
people bought we had so much more cash
flow up front and i'll give you seven
cool upfront offers
that you guys can take home with you
here's a different example b2b agency
all right so a lot of agencies that are
in the lead gen world for small
businesses charge like 1500 bucks a
month
we switch that for the agencies that use
our software
to pay me once and then only pay me
after that if someone shows up we'll
generate the lead we'll work the lead
will do everything if they show up to
the appointment then you pay us how do
you not like that right
we went from the average agency getting
half to one returns on their advertising
to getting 11 to 1 returns before their
retainer before
before they got all the recurring
revenue on the back end which means that
they would make 11 to 1 in that 30-day
cycle they could keep pouring cash in
until
their constraints were operational and
not acquisition based all right so this
is these are the actual numbers of this
example because i thought this would be
relevant for you so if they're spending
ten thousand dollars a month this is
before and after
the same amount of impressions the
response rate is what went through the
roof it was two and a half times higher
percentage of people who responded all
right after that you had a higher
result of people who are
booking there we go look at the
difference in appointments same same
advertising spend
same show rates closing percentage 2.3x
because the offer was better so we
already have a 2.5 and a 2.3 on this
thing let's see how far we can go
and the price we quadrupled the price
we're from a thousand down then 1500 a
month to pay me 4 000 today and that's
it you never have to pay me again unless
someone shows up but that basically just
means we got the first three months up
front
and then we still got paid two days
later when the first person showed up
and so the difference was
making five thousand dollars up front
off your ten thousand dollars
announcement to a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars up front up front an 11
to 11.2 to one return
before
the back end kicked in is that like is
everyone getting this like this stuff
happens now
okay
so you might think that's so neat but
how excellent question so when we're
looking at offers there's seven things
that i'm looking at so how can i how can
i improve this offer so whatever it is
if you're the business owners which is
why i asked you to raise your hand you
have control over this the first thing
is what is the promotion it's either
going to be free discount or premium all
right basically if it's not a free or
discount it's premium the second is the
core offer which is the main thing it's
the steak not the sizzle and i'll get to
that i'll explain the difference in a
second
the bonuses these are the things that
are provided in addition to the main
thing dude
scarcity we have x left and i'll show
you how to do these even if you don't
have x left and do it morally and
ethically all right urgency i'll show
you how to
configure the offer so it feels like it
ends tomorrow even though it may not
necessarily end tomorrow but it does in
the way that you can position i'll
explain how all right
guarantee i'll show you how to stack
guarantees like if anyone have a
guarantee i'll show you how to have
multiple guarantees everyone's stack
guarantees before very interesting i'll
show you how all right and then seven is
the magic naming formula so one of the
cool things about this is that if you
run this play over time it gets tired
like the marketplace has seen it before
and so i'll show you how to reskin the
same thing over and over and over again
that's what allows you to get evergreen
lead generation so free so quick point
on this if i'm starting with a new
business i pretty much always start with
something free
and i do that because the first thing
i'm going to do is always create flaw i
create flow then i monetize the flow and
then i add friction so if you're like
man i'm so worried about being
overwhelmed with leads i'm like well
[ __ ] you all right so
so the point is is that typically free
offers will convert it five to ten times
any other type of offer all right so
i'll always start here and then try and
use my brain to figure out how can i
turn something that's free into
something i can get paid for i'm going
to give you seven offer structures to
show you how to do that there's 19 in
total you get the rest of my my book for
10
and this is where i start every business
all right so that's free second is
discounts one thing that's important to
look at with discounts is that there's
four different ways of displaying them
all right so if you have a discount
offer right now that's tired you can
redisplay the same thing in different
ways so you could say it's x percentage
off you could also flip it and say what
the absolute amount is off you can say
the relative amount so it could be like
it's enough to save your entire your
entire month's mortgage if yours b to b
or b to c
um or or it's enough to get a steak
dinner once a week in savings right so
it's how to display the same thing in
different ways right and then the final
way is doing is just saying what the
price is now versus what it was before
all right so it's four different ways
you can display a discount and that's
what will keep your promotion fresh and
then obviously finally is the premium
offer um this is you know what i call
straight for the jugular this is when
you're selling your hundred thousand
dollar day um
what's interesting about when you do
premium offers most of the time you just
need to charge way more than you think
you should and then these the economics
behind this can get really wild because
in terms of return on ad spend if i'm
selling 100 000 500 000 million dollar
things
the other people i'm competing against
usually aren't selling anything close to
those types of prices and so that's how
we can get 30 to 150 to 1 returns on
advertising on a regular basis because
if you looked at 36 to 1 that means half
of my advertising has gotten me more
than 36 to one return wild right and so
it's because we we use premium offers
but we layer them after so bring them in
free and then we'll upsell them through
premium stuff so that's number one
number two is the main thing all right
the stake most of times when someone is
is is working on an offer of some type
they've got some sort of service it's
really boring and it's not very uh
attractive right and so there are four
variables to value that we've broken
down after looking at this at a lot of
times and look at a lot of offers the
first is the dream outcome all right so
everything on the top side of this
equation is stuff that people value they
want more of this this is great we try
and increase this
the bottom side of the equation is stuff
that detracts from the experience that
makes them less likely to want to buy
all right so the time delay effort and
sacrifice all right as i've studied as a
quick aside as i've studied
bigger more successful businesses
i noticed that in my beginner days i
focused a lot more here on promising
more trying to paint this beautiful
vision of the future when i look at
netflix and amazon and these guys who
are trying to make seamless experiences
so that thoughts can become
you know drones delivering packages that
are door is they're trying to eliminate
as much effort sacrifice and time as
possible for their customers and that is
how they're increasing value and so as
we've shifted our businesses we focus a
lot more on this now than we did here
but just something to consider
all right i'll give you an example of
each one if i'm trying to get brad to
give me money i'm probably going to say
hey brad let me show you how to do this
marketing stuff for lightspeed rather
than hey i'm going to get you a six-pack
why because for him he values that more
and so whatever the thing is that you're
selling the audience now for a woman it
might be different right but for the
avatar painting the dream outcome will
increase the value right making sure
that
that once like it's to compare two
different offers right b to b versus b
to c
once if you're comparing two things in
the exact same market that are savings
that are satisfying the same need i'll
just use weight loss as an example
because everyone understands that one
then then you kind of move on to the
next step in the equation the next is
perceived likelihood of achievement so
if i have somebody who's a plastic
surgeon and they say they can do a tummy
tuck and this guy's done this is his
first surgery he's ever done you got
another guy who's done ten thousand
surgeries are you willing to pay more
for the guy who's done ten thousand
surgeries same surgery it'll actually
probably take the guy to ten thousand
even less time too because we value the
perceived likelihood of achieving our
goal
right certainty and decreasing risk is
something that we value so if you can
think about ways that you can decrease
the perceived risk in the customer's
minds and i'll show you more tactics
about that later but if this is where
the social proof this is where the
testimonials wall this is where the
video the video that you have them watch
watching the lobby of the of the lady
whose life got changed all of that stuff
will literally increase the value of
what you were selling without having to
do anything to it it's simply the
perception of the value now that's the
top side of the equation that's kind of
the easy part i'll make you a lot of
money and uh here's all these people
that made money too right
the bottom side is where it gets
interesting
so time to life there's two components
of time delay to increase the value of
the product that you're selling one is
the immediate first first outcome so for
example um if a girl comes to work out
at the gym oh he's weight loss right and
she feels better the first day she has
she has an immediate value
receipt of value right she doesn't look
better but she feels better right and so
you want to have some sort of first win
early but the second piece is how long
is it going to really take so and so to
hit their goal right if it's going to
take them a year if i can get if i can
if i can shrink the time horizon then i
will increase the value of the product
from selling one of the easiest and best
ways to make a product more valuable is
look at what everyone else can do in a
time period
and cut it in half and then deliver that
it's the easiest thing in the world to
sell speed
people love speed all right and so if we
can shrink the time delay between when
they buy and when they get our product
becomes more valuable the next one is
effort and sacrifice
so if i'm if i'm trying to sell suzy q
on losing weight and i say you've got
two options here right option one is you
can give up everything you love you can
wake up at four o'clock the morning
every day you can be sore as hell you
have to eat separately from your family
uh
you know what i mean all the you know
you got to have people laugh at you you
got a brisk injury all of that stuff you
know by the way it's going to take 12
months maybe right for you to get to
where you want to go right
or
you can just breathe in some gas and
wake up skinny which one is she going to
pick
right
reality is
that's why the same outcome is 50 000
for one and you got to arm wrestle
someone for an hour to get closing for a
thousand dollar deal
for training or gym membership right
it's because
the same dream outcome has she knows
she's probably not going to show up to
the gym so her perceived likelihood of
achievement's low
she knows it's going to take her [ __ ]
forever she's got to give up everything
she loves
right and she's gonna also have to it's
like the only thing she's gonna enjoy is
the fact that she feels better and
that's it and so if you can look at
these four variables within the context
of what you are selling you can
manipulate these to make the core thing
more valuable simply by changing their
perception around it so that's the main
thing that's the stake right that's the
main step that we're offering so first
is we're going to try and figure out if
we can do some sort of free or discount
version the second is we look at the
main thing to see if there's ways that
we can make the thing more valuable
third
now notice when you have free or
discount you can give away bonuses as
part of the free thing and then upsell
the core thing right which i'll get to
in a minute but
the bonuses are things that we've
provided in addition to the main thing
all right so
for example
when i used to sell those boot camps i
was talking about earlier
i was selling 99 month boot camp i was
throwing everything i possibly could i
was like i'll do your food i'll give you
massages i'll drive you home like
whatever you want please sign up right
what's interesting is that if i just say
hey you get the workouts
but if you sign up today i'll also give
you food preparation instructions and
eating out guide you know grocery list
i'll give you uh
how to you know how to eat on the
weekends how to drink alcohol and stay
skinny like all of these extra bonuses
but only if you sign up today all of a
sudden my core offering which is
literally the same thing i was doing
before
is perceived as more valuable and this
is what it looks like visually
because you make the ask after the core
offer right if you're selling
and then if they say no or they say need
to think about whatever right that's
when you start stacking because when
someone sits down like the whole time
the first thing you present after you've
been selling this whole period of time
that's what they anchor with so just
like there's a price anchor there's a
product thinker and so they think in
their mind this is what he's been trying
to sell me this whole time
and so they're going to anchor okay well
i tried to compare this price to this
product but then what i do is you stack
and stack and stack and stack and stack
and stack and then all of a sudden the
product the bonuses seem like such a
steal compared to the thing that i
originally mentioned that it's like why
be a [ __ ] idiot to not say yes today
so when you can stack this stuff it also
gives you a really nice way to get
around the whole discount thing
so rather than rather than be like well
let me talk to my manager and get you 10
off it's like well how about we throw
this instead let me throw you this
instead let me throw you this instead on
top right and so that way it gives the
sales guys like our guys have a huge
vault of private client private access
client materials that they can use to
close deals
and they have street value because
they're listed right some extent so you
can literally make products put them on
your site you might sell it might not
doesn't matter the point is that they're
perceived as valuable and then you can
sell something for two thousand dollars
and give them fifteen thousand dollars
of prizes whatever upsell the bonuses i
have more bonuses there are always more
bonuses i have lots of bonuses okay
so that's the sizzle right so the steak
and then that's the sizzle
so if i'm looking at a business the
first thing i'm looking at the promotion
the next thing is i'm gonna see how i
can adjust the stake and make it more
valuable see if i can change and alter
services around that would cut the time
in half decrease the effort that they
have to put in increase the likelihood
that they think they're gonna achieve it
and then right when they're about to
make a decision i say oh by the way
that's just this big let me tell you
about all this other [ __ ] that we're
going to do for you and they're like
holy crap i'm definitely going to sign
up oh by the way
i only have two spots left and i have 16
more appointments this week so what do
you want to do right and so then we have
scarcity all right so there's three ways
that i've seen how to do scarcity
ethically all right one is if you
actually have a limited supply that's
awesome right but one of the things you
can do is you can have a limited supply
of bonuses so you don't have to say you
have a limited supply of the core thing
i could have limited supply of the
bonuses that i'm giving in and i can
re-wrap the bonuses in different ways
re-skin them put on a new headline or
whatever to change make the same thing
different which i'll show you is the
seventh step of this thing is
re-skinning them so that i can pretty
much always have limited bonuses that i
can always provide scarcity with does
that make sense yes okay so those are
the scarcity pieces all right
urgency this one is probably the one i
use more than scarcity to be candid with
you all right because i think it's
easier to run on a regular basis so just
a quick side note the difference between
scarcity and urgency is scarcity as a
function of units units or quantity
urgency is a function of time
people want to kind of lop them in
together they're different all right so
the first one and this is probably the
one that i use the most all right is
cohort based urgency so it's like hey
we've got a new group of clients
starting on monday you're not going to
miss out we've got a bunch of awesome
killers in that group
right it's it's thursday right and
they're like oh well i don't want to
miss that group like yeah you should do
it the guys are awesome just get started
it just gives you this little nudge now
when she signs up if she says no and
comes back on monday i'm like you should
see the nest group it's good that you
missed this room because the next one's
even better and it starts on monday
right and so you always have this
rolling cohort that can happen which
you're probably already doing you're
just not selling it the next kind of
urgency is uh it's name based urgency so
this is where you can reskin the same
offer and say hey um this this promotion
like you should enter promotions every
month and just reskin them and then
start it so that you just have this
false urgency it's not false it's real
urgency but
it's saying the new year thing ends in
our brazilian special foreclosure school
ends january 31st well guess what we've
got closers for lovers opening in
february which then closes february 28th
and so it's the same program it's just
the promotion is different and the
promotion can still even be the same
price points you just name it different
but that promotion is technically over
right so you can happily get around um
and use urgency and scarcity to your to
your advantage
the promotion of pricing and the bonuses
themselves each of those to be exploding
which leads me to the exploding piece
which is the next one
this is if there is a way right now
where anything in your marketplace is sh
is changing it's shifting
um
this this sounds like crazy if you can
get like if you're for example if i was
saying you know what it's not about
newsfeed ads anymore it's all about
inbox leads right because dms on social
media you're getting direct to the
decision makers and the software that we
have does it for eight dollars and 33
cents a day and delivers 13 to 15 fresh
leads in your inbox as anybody who
responds back right but the thing is a
lot of people can get in on this soon so
you're going to want to sign up now so
you can get a disproportionate amount of
the gains right so this exploding
opportunity is arbitrage so if you can
think of ways that you have your own
product and make it into an exploding
opportunity it'll create more urgency to
take action uh number six this is really
cool
so most people either don't do
guarantees or just do one and they
really lame boring guarantee but most
people don't do two all right so i'll
show you how this works so
i got this closed from jason flatland
and it's one of my favorite closes of
all time and so when he's closing
someone if he has her hat ever has a
30-day satisfaction guarantee love her
to leave it whatever you want to say you
say hey
i'm not asking to say yes or no today
i'm just asking you to make an informed
decision which you can only do on the
inside of the program which basically
gets them to delay the decision by
buying it's [ __ ] awesome
and so if you ever have stuff like every
single person if you have a 30-day lover
to leave a guarantee you can basically
get people to you can make them feel
safe get them to say no hey would you be
opposed to moving forward today i
wouldn't be opposed to moving forward
today cool because i'm not asking to
make a decision right now i'm just
saying i just want you to make an
informed decision which only do once you
start with us right and we can only make
this kind of guarantee because we know
we're so good at what we do and we know
people would say otherwise we wouldn't
be in business right right okay cool so
let's get started so that guarantee is
[ __ ] awesome
and so if you can do an under
conditional guarantee i would highly
highly recommend it here's what's cool
you can have an unconditional guarantee
that's based on one timeline
and then you can have a conditional
guarantee that's based on another
timeline so it's like not only that and
this is the one that you make crazy
all right so this is when you say hey
not only that if you don't make 10 grand
using my software in the first 30 day in
the first 60 days i'll give you 10 grand
because that's how i know it how good it
is but you got to show up to every one
of the calls that we have you got to
make sure all your payments are on time
you've got to xyz the things that are
your activation points for your service
or product the things that you know will
make someone actually successful and
then you just bake those right into your
conditional guarantee and so they're
like wait so if i love her to leave it
and you're telling me that 60 days from
now like if i don't achieve this crazy
result if i do these three things
then
like that's all you need me to do to buy
and there's only two spots left and so
when we stack these things you can
massively increase the closing
percentages for the team and make the
offer more compelling from a marketing
perspective last one okay magic naming
formula so how to name how to use the
same offer and rename it reskin it over
and over again this is especially
important if you if you're in local
markets
so uh i'll give you i'll give you an
interesting one so let's say you've got
this this big bundle i was talking about
the 360 challenge i told you about
earlier right so let's say that that's
our that's our original bundle it's
fitness and nutrition stuff right
then we call it the fall
six week challenge
then we call it our spring 28 day
blueprint then we call it our
halloween 42 day detox
same exact thing
it just keeps it fresh and so that way
we don't have to change the operational
structure of the business but we can
constantly keep the marketing fresh
all right
okay
and that's the uh that's what the magic
stands for so it's the magnet which is
make a magnetic reason which is why i
like having a reason why of some sort
it's like it's fall it's spring it's
whatever right it's you know my kid lost
a tooth it's our fifth year anniversary
right which is a great one we just
started running a fifth year anniversary
ad that's why i'm running this offer and
people like oh that's why he's running
the office like i ran the offer last
month too but now it's our fifth year
anniversary right and the thing is is
you can be like it's my wife's birthday
it's my birthday it's my company's
birthday it's like three times a year
you already got birthdays so you can
give reasons why for it right like you
can always i always used to i always
tell people think like a fraternity
party planner just like you need this
much to create to have a party it's like
stu got his wisdom teeth out rager right
so it's the same idea in terms of reason
why
okay so we have our magnetic reason we
have we announced the avatar so we say
who we're looking for so it's you know a
little black dress which would prob that
would include that would be implied
sorry uh bad example uh
six week you know guys
uh you know lean down
i said six week already and then the
container would be like takedown or
whatever right uh blueprint jumpstart
kickstart you know sprint accelerator
whatever right the point is that we put
these things together now you don't have
to have all of them but if you just have
these on the back of your mind you'll
always be able to spin headlines very
quickly and name products and offerings
um that will convert
those are the seven things that i look
at when i'm trying to adjust a
business's offer to make the marketing
more compelling and get more clicks
check number two
you guys with me so far we still good
all right cause i'm about to show you
one of the sexiest things that i have
all right so i can guarantee everyone
here that you will get more customers
from the thing i'm going to show you so
yes i guess a couple people moved around
in their chairs fantastic this is our
pond
we have our little our little wormy guy
and now we got to put in the pond so we
got to find our pawns never go hungry
again this is actually the the photo
shop uh the ceo is like this is my never
go hungry again framework so he has this
posted behind his computer so he knows
that there's always ways to get more
customers you can take a picture of this
because this is this is like my holy
grail if i ever need more business this
is where i go all right so you've got
paid media you have earned media you
have phone media you have outbound you
have affiliates and partners in your
referrals and i'll show you the the ways
that we use each of these um i've i've
done
i've done 20 million out of every single
one of these boxes except for earns
media um so that's actually the one that
and i'm just starting doing that now um
but the other five or whatever um i've
made over 20 million from each so i'll
tell you like i'll tell you what we do
right now that's working um and so yeah
i'm going to show you a lot of [ __ ] here
you're probably not gonna like just pick
one or two that you actually will do and
like if you do that then you can go to
the next one like give yourself
permission to do the next one if you
just do one of them okay so paid media
and i've got one for you in this one
okay so remember we have our little
equation we've got to make more in the
first 30 days and it costs two buy two
customers and fulfill two customers all
right so if you if you don't have an
action this is the action for you just
spend 100 bucks a day on those lead ads
that don't sell you all right if you do
this give give yourself a slush fund
there we go give yourself a slash fund
one of the one of the early marketing
mentors that i had told me
instead of buying all these courses and
coachings and whatever
just say whatever amount of money you're
willing to blow every month on
advertising and then always spend it
and that way it'll force you to do it
and the thing is is you won't have your
ego tied up and you're not gonna be like
[ __ ] i suck it's like well i'm supposed
to suck i don't know what i'm doing but
you will figure it out i promise you if
you actually just spend and i just
recommend people start 100 bucks a day
and you'll start to see some traction
you'll watch some more youtube videos
and you'll learn a lot faster than
all the many many many things that you
that are out there okay cool so these
are the examples of paid media youtube
facebook instagram influencer shoutouts
is actually underrated podcast gdn
podcast meeting you can get the insert
the you can pay the person to basically
say commercial like radio uh gdn search
radio branded search is a hack that i'll
show you in a second that just about
everyone here is losing money
all right it'll give you like your
highest return on advertising so this is
our advanced lead generation got a
little magnety guy a little promotion
then what we do is we give them some
offer to liquidate our acquisition costs
our upfront cash offer that's how we get
all that money back we have two ups we
have upsell down cell and every single
this this is literally every single
offer that i've home runs has been every
single one of them has looked just like
this and then we feed them in a condo
day
one two three four that's what we do
over and over and over again so i'm
gonna give you one cool this is probably
this is the thing that i'm most excited
about stuff that i love more than
anything i literally wrote a book just
on this one topic so these are free cash
offers so you're like how do i make
money if i'm giving something away for
free excellent question brad there we go
limited free this is an example limited
free is someone comes in for xy service
that you should always know more about
your service than they do and give
i don't want to say an incomplete
solution but give a solution that's not
going to
i'll give you a simple example if
someone were getting a car wash it would
be like the the lowest bare minimum the
car is not even gonna look that much
better we'll look better but not that
much better right or if someone is
coming in to work out at the gym or
rather if someone's coming to lose
weight right i'll say you can have
access to our group and we'll give you
homework outs while they're at the gym
and they're like but like or you can do
our super sexy guaranteed results double
guaranteed has all these bonuses and
it's only this for you right now to
start some money you should definitely
get into it well guarantee you lose 10
pounds in the first 30 days if you don't
we'll keep working you for another 30
days
fair enough
right and so that is someone someone
comes in for something free we give them
an inferior offer and then we upsell
them the primary offer all right that's
what we call limited free
by the way you also don't even have to
mention the inferior offer because half
the time they don't remember more than
half the time second one free with
deposit that was the thing that i
mentioned earlier if you ever have any
kind of service that it requires effort
on behalf of the customer to get a
result
anything that's a lot of services right
you can market something for free and
have that like if you did therapy you
did life coaching you did anything that
is some sort of like the client has to
do something
you have to pay for the program and then
if they get the outcome
or if they do the habits
they can get the program free or rebated
or credited back to them right towards
future services
does that make sense it's pretty cool
this one [ __ ] kills this one is
awesome
i'm telling you this one is awesome this
was made more money than any offer on
this board because what it does is it
aligns the customer with the result when
they don't have the they use the money's
accountability so your client's success
scores go through the roof and it's like
well marjorie if you lose 22 pounds in
your first six weeks working with me are
you going to keep you're going to want
to come to me for the next 40 and she's
like oh absolutely you're like well
that's that's why we do the promotion so
i'm not worried about giving you six
weeks free if i get six years shortly
right but if you follow the money from
what i said earlier she got six weeks
free
because we took the money and we credit
it against her future rate which you
probably put up a little bit and then
discounted it off the money that you got
does that make sense threes okay
giveaways giveaways are awesome the way
you do giveaways properly have a first
place prize and a second place prize
this first place prize is your core
offer it's your biggest sexiest most
expensive package
you do that because then everyone knows
the price
and you market you are going to give
that one away for free and the second
place prize is an acceptable discount
and absolute value so for example if i
was giving away
god what services i don't know a year of
window washing whatever right and it's
the ultra platinum window washing
experience whatever
underneath of that let's say that was a
four thousand dollar deal
underneath that i would say second place
prize gets six hundred dollars
of window washes right
you run the promotion you wait four days
give them the countdown of when the when
the person's gonna
get to get called
then you announce the winner pick one
person everyone else congratulations you
won second prize right you can put in
the in the thing more than one winner
may apply you're completely compliant
all right and by doing that you give
every single person a 600 off your 4 000
package
neat
this works really well you want to get
leads this works
okay
free with prepay this is also one of my
favorites so if anybody here has uh
recurring services or bundled services
if you're trying to get upfront cash
which is this guy
then you can sell like buy three get
free and you can double the price for
the thing
so you're still selling six months up
front basically but it's buy three get
free for buy six get six whatever
and that can go with products or to go
with time it doesn't really matter but
when you do this though you get so much
cash flow up front you can you can
pretty much out market all your
competition
it's very cool and churn on prepaid
people is one-fifth of month-to-month
people fyi
splinter-free
so if you have a type of service or work
that has to be done in that's the same
thing that has to be done multiple times
so an example would be a chiropractor
or a massage therapist somebody who has
this who does the same service over and
over again one of the best things to do
is just do a splinter free offer which
means you pull one of them off right
ideally you want to pull one of them off
and like tanning is a really good
example i'll use that one
like if i said i'm going to give you a
five day free vip tanning experience
person comes in they're super excited we
say hey how tan do you want to get i'm
going to show you this book of tana be
like the chocolate one like okay well
you look like vanilla so it's going to
take us a lot more than five days to get
there so you want to get there cool then
why don't we just sign you up for a
membership
right because you can't tan five days in
a row you tend once in five days because
otherwise you'll burp
because we know more about our service
than our customer does so there's a lot
of things that your customer wants but
they don't know how to get there we can
make promotions that in their mind it's
like oh it's like five day weight loss
it's like no one loses
right but in their minds you can then
educate them so they're better consumers
and then make a better more informed
buying decision once kim really
understands that she's vanilla and she
wants to get the chocolates take more
than five days we're already here and
you like me because i'm smiling and
being nice
she'll sign up right and so this offer
works very very well you break off one
piece same thing like laser hair removal
you can't do one session laser hair
removal you need all six right there's
lots of things like that you can break
off one or two and they can't really do
that without the other ones that's you
give the two for free because you know
it'll bring them in and this one this is
one of my favorites so for this event
for example if i were to do invisible
freight what invisible free offer is is
i say hey
you can come to this event absolutely
free but you put your credit card in at
the end of the event if you don't think
it was worth five grand you just let me
know after the first day and i'll i'll
send you uh you know we won't bill your
card but the upsell that you're selling
right there's or
you can pay right now for three grand
and get all the recordings
and
and and so you have this thing that's
marketed for free the down sell is they
sign up for something more expensive
right the down sell is they sign up for
something more expensive that gets them
less
right and then you say
if you don't think it's worth x y and z
then we won't bill you but the
requirement of that is you have to show
up this works with like webinars too
same thing if you if you're worried
about people showing up there's also a
great way to get people to show up right
if you're ever doing like a pitching
thing too
now they have their credit card like
there's different strategies to use this
one for like if you wanted everyone to
pitch you could down sell everyone into
just staying and offloading it so you
make the prices closer if you want more
people to pay today make the price
discrepancy bigger add more bonuses
so if it's like 250 and 200
well then i'll wait i'll wait for 250 or
200 and then i get everyone to show up
because the only way they can not get
billed is by showing up and then you
have everyone's captive attention you
can pitch your ass off all right this is
for brad
so this is the easiest hack that
everyone in the entire world can do that
you probably aren't doing
own your damn terms so this is literally
on the on the plane today lightspeed lms
everybody else is paying for your terms
all these guys are they their marketing
guys are doing it and you're here
right so it's like i got gotta say no to
all these guys before i see yours and
then
everybody who's got an android
you're not even coming up right and so
it's just like if you just own your
brand of terms the return on on ad spend
for branded terms is stupid it's like 20
to 40 to one it's crazy and it's so easy
to set up google how to set up branded
search terms 10 minutes and then you can
put all these in and guarantee you like
all you do is you send them to a landing
page that just says email opt-in phone
number like simple because they're
already looking for you they're just the
lowest low toss leads out there but just
make sure that they're seen so it's
branded search you're just you're just
literally owning your own keywords you
say i want to advertise for bradley
lightspeed uh lightspeed lms lightspeed
training light speed like all the
variations of that someone might be
searching
paid media number one you're like oh
[ __ ] don't worry the other ones are
faster
okay earn media i'll just give you a
quick strategy for this most you guys
have lists and contacts all right so my
recommendation from a strategy
perspective
is to do a quarterly push i'll just move
a little faster for you so when you're
doing content like you kill it with
content right so the strategy that we
see that works is just
let them know what you do
not a pitch just let hey it's bradley
from lightspeed and this is what we do
and if you're one of those guys awesome
then we have all the value we give and
by the way if you're one of those people
that has this problem that we solve you
should xyz right so you don't lose
anything from those people when you do
that on a regular basis
and then this is what um most people are
missing
which is a quarterly push all right so
that means once a quarter you do a four
day blitz on your list and that's where
you promote like [ __ ] crazy for four
days and they shut it with real scarcity
on an offer and that way you can click
you can squeeze your list every quarter
and most people aren't doing this so if
i'm going to go buy a business or buy a
piece of a business i'm looking through
this checklist that i'm going through
right now the offer the client finance
acquisition for the math and then what
traffic sources we're using and i'm just
checking boxes i'm like oh registers
let's get it in uh let's do this and i
just keep plugging these holes and just
like that at the end they triple their
acquisition right this is just a
checklist
all right next one
owns media this is actually very similar
same concept this is from your followers
where you're promoting it and saying it
on your podcast here you're saying it's
your list that you owe
everything else is more or less the same
all right the difference here is that
this is email list messenger lists sms
list blog audience contacts in your
phone depending on depending on how many
contacts you're from phone this is a
really good one right now
this is dean jackson's nine word email
still one of the best emails like ever
written it's called the nine word email
because it has nine words in it
and it says do you still need help
getting that problem solved
that's it you email your list that i
guarantee you will get people respond
back saying yes i do actually still need
help solving that problem that you saw
nothing else don't get like don't say by
the way like nine words are you still
struggling with are you still struggling
with issue
all right outbound
just fyi i mean i know you guys are more
in the sales sales world
but we get ridiculous roi on outbound so
we have a 20 outbound team
my hack here is to use multiple forms i
know that the software does that too but
you get way better conversions if you
contact on multiple channels all right
uh from a strategy perspective really
quick
uh if you're starting out on this
channel
i just tell everyone 100 reach out today
100 a day guaranteed you will make more
money and i give people six months when
i give it six months like it snowballs
but
i haven't yet to have somebody not kill
it within six months if they do that so
that's just a simple strategy and it
works very very well um these still work
because i feel like people have
forgotten this i don't know why
at least in the marketing world
everyone's forgotten about it so it's
like blue ocean for us first thing to do
is to call your own leads right seems
obvious that sometimes people have so
many leads i talked to a lot of
marketers who've never talked to early
system why
so first thing to do would be to call
your own leads um
next uh i spent fifty thousand dollars
in like coaching and programs and stuff
to like learn outbound
didn't use any of it i think the best
thing is to just start because every
there's enough
nuances to every niche it's worth just
like you'll figure it out and that's
what we ended up doing anyways on our
own
um and then yeah give it six months and
then we put ten to twenty percent of our
i said marketing budget even though i
said it didn't say but what we currently
spend on advertising we put 10 to 20 of
that towards outbound not expecting an
roi for the first two months
and it took like a quarter basically it
took like a quarter to roi but now it's
about 20 to 1 for us
in terms of return which is really good
okay all right affiliates and partners
all right
so if i'd say the ones that i've made
the most money from
one
two
lots and lots from these
so
one of the things that our goal here for
this is to get is to be a full
integration so a lot of people do like
hey talk at my thing or do a webinar
with me or do a podcast with me and that
stuff's great but i mean it's like
you'll see a little blip but i want full
integration and so what i try to figure
out is who has problems that i can solve
so for example if i were going after
personal trainers i would go after a
software that caters to personal
trainers i would find out that the
biggest problem that those people have
is that the trainers need their first
five clients for the software for them
to stick because people don't use crms
if they don't have c's customers right
you can't use the crm so if you don't
have customers and so i can say hey mr
software guy you've got 14 000 personal
trainers and i want to sell stuff to
personal trainers i know how to get them
clients
why don't you send them to me and i'll
solve your biggest problem with
activation
and so the idea is i want to get into
their onboarding process the reason
prestige labs which is our supplement
company which does more revenue than my
gym company does is because we use the
distribution base and integrated the
supplement cell into the onboarding
process at every gym that we work with
and so when someone when kimberly comes
in she buys services but 48 hours later
we're doing a nutrition consultation
we're selling them supplements and so
that all of the marketing has been that
all my partners are spending it flows
through big
and they're happy to do it because they
get paid handsomely and i'm happy to do
it because i don't have to pay for
acquisition
now there's two ways that you can use
this strategy that i like
one of them is what i just said where
you integrate where they're doing the
promoting and selling your stuff the
other way is where you're doing the
promoting and selling their stuff where
you actually become the affiliate and if
you're making
if you were if you're not sending too
much money away a lot of times it's a
lot less work to just be an affair you
can get 40 50 of top line revenue that
you're sending over someone for none of
the work most businesses don't run with
50 margins so if you can get 50 of top
line and do none of the fulfillment and
you're already paying for the traffic
anyways why not
and then if that person you're from the
business owner also has that list you
can you can say you know what i'll refer
all those people over just send some
people back right and that may sound
silly but if you do it on a regular
basis people will do it but you have to
do it first you have to sell their thing
first and then they will return it all
right so um
can't really see it but
for prestige labs we have 4 000
affiliates
that are brick and mortar mom and pop
shops that sell our products
allen is the software that we use we
have
uh 200 or 400 now 400 agencies that
white label our product and then sell it
on our behalf and they make tons of
money doing it we just make a little
piece in all of it
right and so it's how can i find ways to
make other people money and then
integrate
so these are the quick strategies and
then we'll get to the
the six ways to make more money on
customers um okay so this is a different
example that i'll share with you so uh i
was working with a company recently the
hybrid for consulting stuff and they
they catered a physical therapist
and so they were like how can we do this
partner integration and i was like well
what do you what do all
pts sell to every client that who uses
physical therapists as a distribution
mechanism to get to customers p to b to
c they're like well orthotics braces
like recovery bands all that stuff it's
like right reach out to those companies
and say hey
give me ten of your guys
i'll teach them how to sell your product
in exchange for you just sending more of
your guys for me to teach them how to
sell your product i'll also sell them my
product
but i'm selling more of your [ __ ] for
you people will feed you like tons if
you can solve this problem for them so
like if if you can because most you guys
here know how to sell so a lot of people
don't know their clients they have
people who don't sell their products you
can take their customers teach them how
to sell their own product better and
then they will feed people to you
because you're solving their problem
we kill it with this
and primary action for anyone here who's
an action taker
you can do 100 reach out today or just
identify the 10 biggest partners and
then spend real money to get them
like real money you know what i mean
send them a tv send them a watch send
them something they can't ignore show up
at their office and should be like can i
plea i just i've got bags of money i
want to throw you please please let me
just give that light to you because it's
just burning a hole in my wallet right
and usually people will take that that
meeting
also if you send if you send letters
with like a thousand dollars a day in
cash people tend to return the calls
you do okay affiliate partners last one
referrals and then we'll get to ltv so
this is the golden ratio um 30 of our
customers still come from referrals our
goal is the companies to get the
percentage of customers who refer to be
greater than percentage of customers who
leave
if you can achieve this you have
limitless growth
it's just like the client finest
acquisition of customer success if we
can get a higher percentage of customers
to send us someone than to leave our
business will grow with nothing else and
so that is our golden ratio so that's
the goal with referrals
so here are some examples of stuff that
we do for incentives i'm going to give
you a really sexy one right now
so obviously this is the there's the
cash one
the unlockable bonus is something that's
really nifty and so if you have a vip
service or some sort of thing that's of
value like those bonuses i was talking
about like something that's really
sizzle right it could be a it could be a
software feature it could be a
it could be a training it could be a it
could be anything that you can think of
but
especially if it's something that gives
status
then you say hey they're like what are
world those guys got those fancy bands
like oh those are just for people who
send us other clients who don't hate
their friends you hate your friends
because you haven't done this anymore i
don't know why you hate your friends so
much right and so when you do that it's
like a it's like a classy way of paying
someone without having to pay the cash
tickets to events all those types of
things work really well for referrals
all right do you know anybody who's
looking to achieve x that's probably one
of the best um
outbound openers by the way because then
you don't feel like you're spamming
someone and they're like you know what
[ __ ] my sister i'm the one who needs to
lose weight right and then they tell you
okay uh cash bonuses integrated yeah and
then i would make sure that you have
this integrated in the onboarding
process i know some of this stuff some
of you guys may have heard of but you
might still not do them
every company that i like i work with
they're like yeah yeah right ask for
referrals i'm like are you like we've
been meaning to
like why aren't you where is it in the
process right just show me where it is
in the process and then we make sure it
happens every time
and then one of the biggest pieces here
that's the last one i'll say about about
referrals is from from human psychology
as
if i if i take brad to the airport right
and i do cry out a favor immediately
after the favor happens is when brad
feels the most positively towards me and
i actually feel is the doer of the favor
like it wasn't that big of a deal six
months later when we look back on that
situation i feel like i did brad a huge
favor and brad's like there's nothing
send me the airport and so that is why
people have these weird relationships
with businesses sometimes when they
leave because what have you done for me
lately really sits in the thing is the
person who's the doer disproportionately
feels like they did more than they
actually did so you have two different
cognitive biases working against each
other and so
when you're doing testimonials or
referrals the moment you have the
activation point that first positive
magical moment that you probably have
choreographed in your customer
onboarding experience that's when you
ask does everyone know where like their
big magical moment their activation
point of like if someone does this then
they stay 10 months longer or whatever
does everyone know that is if you don't
take your longest customers look at what
they did in their beginning and then try
and model that i'll give you one more
does everyone feel like there's a lot of
different ways we can get customers now
six different pools
do they want to have at least one of
these that you're not doing that you
could immediately just pull cash out of
okay good uh most businesses would do
very well if they just started up by
picking the biggest pile of money in
front of them most of us have these big
bags of money that are sitting in front
of us
that we just don't pick up and so what i
you know what i end up doing for these
companies i just like let's start with
this big pile of money and just take 10
minutes on youtube and get creative
terms up within by by 5 o'clock today
because it takes that long right and
then you have leaflet i've lit i've
never had less than 20 to 40 increase in
number of customers from just doing one
of these things i mean that should cover
a lot of guys growth for this year all
right so we got the math to how to
require customers at a profit the offer
on how to get complete strangers to say
yes because it'd be stupid if they said
no because of all the things you made
where where to dangle that little double
guaranteed super secret double bonus six
week whatever in front of the in front
of their name and then finally how you
become unbeatable all right so this is
where the numbers and metrics become
really cool this is probably the part
that i spent the most time on not
because it's long but because it's sexy
so how to become a beatle make so much
money for a customer that you can use
any channel you damn well please does
anyone feel like it costs too much to
acquire customers one person anyone else
feel like it costs too much required
customers two people anyone else three
people four people five people okay five
people this is for you guys everyone
else chill the thing is is that eyeballs
are never going to get cheaper than they
are today think about it they will
literally never be cheaper than they are
right now and so if you feel like
they're expensive now then what is it
going to be in five years more expensive
i can guarantee you that i will bet
everything i have on the fact that
basically more expensive five years from
now and so this is the only lever that
you can pull
to be unbeatable so that you can
outspend everyone
that way you can use all of these
channels because if you made a million
dollars a deal you could use direct mail
and still work use radio nationally and
still work because you make so much more
per customer right and so as much as
this is an acquisition thing the back
end informs the front end sometimes when
i teach this i go backwards um
so let's play a quick money game it
really likes money games
all right so this is the business genie
exercise
this is our sample business
we get 30 new clients a month one client
a day the average client stays with us
for three months the price per month is
100
we currently have 100 clients we're at a
point of equilibrium that means that
we're not going to grow at this rate
we're not going to shrink at this rate
we're going to stay even
we have 20 margins we're doing 10 000 a
month which means we're taking home 2000
a month sad face
this is our business in this business
genie this beautiful icon of a business
jd business gin if you will shows up and
says
i can double one aspect of your business
which one would you like it to be
it's very it's a niche genius
all right
option number one
i can double the number of new clients
that you sign up every month
option number one
option number two i can double the price
of your product or services
everything else is the same in all these
examples
choice number three
i can double the number of purchases per
customer
which do you choose you only get one
it's a business it's a business genie
all right so do me a favor all right
i'll do raise hands on choice number one
choice number one this one double number
of clients okay
choice number two double price of
product and services
okay
number three double the amount of
purchases everyone makes all right so we
have a really even split which is
perfect all right somebody walk through
some cool [ __ ] with you
so if i double the amount of clients
that i have right that i'm coming in
then i'm going to go from 30 to 60. the
math behind that means that i'm going to
go if the business will double
eventually right because the churn stays
the same it's going to double and it's
going to get to 200 clients at 100 a
month so i'll make 20 grand the 20
margins is 4 grand so i double the
amount of profit did everyone follow me
with that yes
cool so number three
if i double the amount of purchases per
customer it works out to the same thing
because each customer becomes
they buy twice essentially because
they're buying two different things from
us right so we're an easier way to say
this in a recurring business would be
you're doubling the lifespan of the
customer they're buying twice as many
times they go from three months to six
months right we'd be cutting churn in
half this is a different way of saying
it right and so by doing this
this has a slight advantage over number
one does anyone know what it is you
don't have mics i'll tell you what it is
the advantage of this one is that your
your ltv per customer is twice as high
so now i can spend more on the
acquisition right and so the point here
is i'm making twice as much profit per
customer i'm making twice as much profit
in each of these scenarios from a
business standpoint i'm making the same
amount of profit but this is a better
business
because i'll be able to grow this one
more easily now for this example i'm
keeping all their variables the same but
my marketing cost would be half on this
one because i can acquire the same
number of customers to get them to stay
twice as long does that make sense
okay
if you double your price you make six
times the profit
so let me walk you through this
if you're at 100 a month
and your cost of fulfilling was 80
that's the 20 margin we double that we
go to 200 and we're still at 80 to
fulfill so we now have 20
and the 100 in profit
so now we have six times the amount of
profit as we did before
and no one [ __ ] pays attention to
their prices
pricing's everything it's the number one
lever on how much money you make
so
is that cool
this is what we're going to talk about
this is my probably my favorite subject
so that is how important the six levers
that i'm going to share with you are
so when i said make them worth more it's
an increase in lifetime gross profit
now people have heard everyone hear the
term lifestyle value
it's defined
a million different ways if you if you
google it you'll see six different
definitions of it so i will define this
for you
lifetime gross profit
the purple is the juice all right that
is what we that is the squeeze that is
what we get at the end all right that's
the chop that's the gross profit it's
not the chop that's that would be not
profit but the gross profit is the cost
of fulfillment costing goods sold
and then what is left over to them pay
all the other should we have rent all
the other stuff but it comes out of this
right gross profit is 50. this isn't a
good business by the way this is just an
example because it's simple all right so
i'm going to use this as kind of the
case study for all the examples i'm
going to give you and i'm going to show
you every lever that i pull in a
business to make way more money for a
customer all right
so
in this business the lifetime revenue
is 500
lifetime gross profit is 250. everyone's
with me great all right
so if you don't know how to calculate
this in your own business does everyone
know what their number is in their
business lifetime gross profit per
customer
for everyone who didn't say yes here's
how you do it
this is the simple way and then i'll
show you what if you have a recurring
based business
this is the simplest back of napkin way
of doing it
take the total revenue that you've
collected since you started business
literally just add up the bank
statements
times your gross margin we should
already hopefully know what your margin
is on the on the services you deliver
which is like if you do services for
example i pay extra hour it takes y
hours to to get the result why hours
compared to the prices is 20 of the
price that makes sense if i sold
personal trading and it was 20 an hour
and i sold it for 100 bucks i'd have an
80 gross margin
is that fast
okay thank you
so i've got the total money times the
margin
and then i just divided by the total
number of customers i've ever signed up
this will underestimate it but i'd
always rather round down and then make
more money
but this will be the closest estimation
because if you're like well we're better
now than we were before cool that's okay
you can always make more money but it's
better to underestimate these numbers
this is better if you have uh just
selling products or like one-time
purchases
if you have a recurring business or a
business where people will buy more
often
then this is the way you do it same top
line the only thing is different is that
you divide the bottom
uh by total number of churned out
customers
so like if 900 of my thousand customers
have turned
then it's going to be divided by 0.9
which basically makes my ltb go up
because 10 of my customers still are
going to keep paying me does that make
sense i know that was kind of
complicated but does that kind of make
sense i feel like a kinda
all right just go with me don't worry
all right so here's why this is so
important this is probably my favorite
quote of my own
the business owner that can make his
clients more valuable to his business
than his competition wins
all right i even misquoted myself but
that's the idea all right so the idea is
not like i'm not trying to outspend
everyone i'm trying to make this human
being more valuable to me than anyone
else so that means that i'll be able to
acquire him better than anyone else and
so the more i can spend an acquisition
the more channels will be opened up to
me and then the more depth of the
channel i can reach like if i get priced
out of facebook when i spend what's like
once i go past 300 000 of my audience
because it's too expensive to reach the
next part then i get priced out right so
if i can spend more than i can keep
going deeper and deeper into each of the
channels that i have on top of that i
can also get more depth in the actual
market like market penetration because i
can still outspend my competition right
so if you can only spend a dollar to
acquire a customer you'll probably never
be in business and so but no one looks
at this and like my marketing doesn't
work it's probably because your business
doesn't work
right and that's the issue
okay like even facebook which is free
makes forty dollars a year on everyone
crazy right haven't thought about like
two dollars and fifty cents a month goes
to facebook for when you log in for
selling your eyeballs
so this is what it looks like in real
time so this is let's say this is a gym
owner even though he's got a tiny
business thing let's just say it's a
gentleman so there's got you know he's
got old spice marketing to him he's got
he's got equipment manufacturers that's
their ltv
or ltgp excuse me uh then you've got
apparel and then you've got software and
then you've got gym launch me marketing
against
right well i cannot spend all these guys
so this is what happens
i own all of his eyes
his eyes are mine because i can outspend
all of them i'll just i'll artificially
raise the prices
so that they can't bid on his eyes
so it's a ethical i don't know ethical
it's a legal way
to create a monopoly
if i could make so much more money than
the rest of my competitors then i can
own every eyeball that's in my audience
because i'll set the cpm so high no one
else can bid
i'll bid against myself to give them
high
does that make sense
that's like position to [ __ ] you
that's what the back end does okay and
that's why i refer to lifetime gross
profit as the arms race of business like
if you have this you have the biggest
stick
so here's the six ways that i increase
lifetime gross profit
number one you can increase the price
which we did in our little genie example
that's just one of them the second one
is you can reduce the actual cost of
fulfillment and i'll show you some of
the ways that we look at number three is
you can increase the number of purchases
that a customer does number four is you
can upsell them which has two different
types of upsells one is making something
better the other was selling more of the
same thing so one is quality one is
quantity down sells is the opposite of
that so it's poor quality lower quantity
or fewer fewer and then six is cross
sells so it's what's the adjacent need
they're gonna have all right a lot of
people just kind of lock cross cells and
upsells together and i don't like to i
think there's more nuance to them if you
can think as you can think in nuance
you'll act in new ones you'll be able to
think more creatively about the business
so increasing price this one's a quick
one look at the difference in lifetime
revenue and gross profit if i increase
the price by 50
i doubled my profit i have this
conversation with gym owners all the
time on average we increase the
recurring revenue by 38 a month the
average gym makes 12 and a half percent
net margins the average gym is at 129 a
month so if i had 38 dollars and they're
making 12 and a half i just 3.1x their
profit they're like what do i care about
38 bucks i'm like i'm gonna triple your
[ __ ] profit that's why that's why
this is important so number one if
there's a way to increase the perceived
value that's what we do the bait the
bait the offer all that stuff
is so that we can raise the price that
we can make more money number one i told
this one be quicker they're just more
visuals but they're fast
fast and easy that's what my wife called
me here we go so number one is if you
have people in your company that are
doing like basic administrative or even
semi-skilled work you can outsource it
for four dollars an hour to 12 pages and
they do a great job just fyi so you can
probably cut down your cost of
fulfillment for a lot of the services
that you sell or products that you sell
and by doing that you still increase the
margin which increases your lifetime
gross profit which allows you to make
more and spend more aggressively all
right another one that we do uh is tools
and software so like subtitle for
example i've got this video guy that i
paid that i paid that i used to pay to
do all this stuff but now we can do
other stuff right which is like
automatically get the the things
captioned get that nice like meme cover
and like the progress bar it does it all
of that all of that with a click of a
button and so it's like well great well
then now you have all this other time to
do high value stuff rather than do this
this kind of stuff design pickle things
like that so there's software that can
they can take a lot of the high value
labor and just automate it technology so
if you have tech so like our our our
agency software for example makes chat
responses you know it increases the chat
efficiency of a person by about 100 x
all right and so by doing that we make
the cost of fulfilling lead nurturing
100th of what it would normally be and
so i can sell it at a reasonable rate
but it cost me pennies compared to what
it cost my competitors and so when you
have this type of advantage then i can
make ridiculous profits because i'm
pricing at market but it costs me
nothing and so i have so much more room
compared to everyone else
and then forecasting if you're in a
products business
buying wholesale obviously if you have
the cash flow we do that a lot on our
supplement side just to decrease our
description our cost of goods all right
so this is what it looks like visually
and then that's what it looks like so
the top line didn't change but the
bottom line did
that's the difference this still is an
increase in lifetime gross profit check
box number three increase number of
purchases here we go so number one is
decreasing churn which is aka getting
people to buy again all right so that is
providing a better service doing more
activation more onboarding etc number
two is increasing the quality of the
product next was increase follow-ups for
repeat purchases all right so most
people right now don't do any of this
like there's so many ways to reach
people so i told you like there's little
pockets of cash right now in your
business this is probably a pocket of
cash for you just like literally just
waiting for you just like okay
increasing the follow-up and then
finally uh increase client outcome to
increase volume uh for rev share that
was for you right and so if i can if i
can increase the number of purchases
effectively if i have a rev share thing
then how can i increase the outcomes how
can i teach them skills that will make
them more money right so that they will
in turn pay me more money all right and
this is what that looks like
so if i'm increasing number of purchases
i'm not increasing my margin
on a relative basis but on an absolute
basis i now have twice as much as i did
before
is everyone thinking like the purpose of
this is so that you can think about your
own services and products and think oh
that would be an easy thing that i could
do right now just make more money right
these are all the different ways you can
increase the lifetime value of a
customer
upsells all right so there's two types
of upsells
number one is you can sell more of
something one burger goes to two burgers
number two is you can make a better
burger you go from a small burger to a
big burger or a normal burger to an
organic burger whatever two different
types of upsells so right now if you
have a core service if you're thinking
what kind of upsells can i do can i sell
more of it can i sell a better version
of it those are easy things a lot of
times you just survey the customers
asking what they want all right so when
i'm thinking about upsells number one is
units i can sell more web pages if i was
selling a web page service now i can
sell more types of pages right
number two would be like
if i'm selling service
i can sell it by units of time so i've
got units in terms of quantity and i
also have time so if i'm trying to
upsell for more i think about both of
them right so right now if you have
different things inside of your business
like if you're currently selling support
why don't you sell 12 months of support
why don't you sell 24 months of support
if you're selling one one site why don't
we sell a 10 tab website it's units
right there's always more units you can
sell if you think if you think you're a
problem next one is survey says
morse this is what it looks like
visually boom so now you'll notice again
this is the same duration of time
they're not staying longer necessarily
but we're getting them to buy more of
the same thing that's why the margins
are the same right i'm going to show you
a different example later where the
margins are different
all right so now this is the second type
of upsell which is better all right so
you've got let's say normal service and
that could give you expert service
that's quality right a different version
of quality just because i like to give
examples
is the enhanced burger like i said
earlier
before that you've got web page design
and then you've got web page design that
loads really fast
speed
remember they said the value equation
these are the values quality
time
decrease after preference degrees effort
and sacrifice decrease time right those
are the things that you're reversing
when you're thinking about your upsells
right
another version of this
if you have a slow burger or a fast
burger right you can wait 20 minutes for
you to get in three it's more valuable
right so you can upsell that same with
service do you have chat support where
do you have phone call support that's an
upsell right so that's access and
convenience and in the burger example
are you are you eating at home or is it
getting delivered all right so if i'm
thinking about upsells for enhancements
that are better you've got quality
you've got speed and you've got access
and convenience
so right now does anyone can anyone
think of something they should be
upselling that's one of these things
in your own business great awesome
so pro tip is anyone here competing
against somebody who gives their stuff
away for free like what you sell
sometimes it happens in software so
if you're ever competing against a free
competitor
the only thing that beats free is speed
fast beats free
if once a year chipotle gives away a
free burrito to anyone who dresses like
a burrito
and if i want to get chipotle on
halloween i gotta wait two hours if
there was a line next to the free line
for ten dollars to buy chipotle i would
pay the ten dollars to not get the free
burrito and wait
people pay for speed so fast speed's
free a lot of people think about the
components of time for their offers
okay
with better it's the same concept all
right but you'll notice
with this upsell
i can make much more profit
right and so
interestingly your upsell can have a lot
more profit than your core offer cam
right
which is pretty nifty i have the numbers
over here if you're seeing them in the
hypotheticals
and so this is a quick pro tip for you
as well if you are doing upsells many
times you want the upsell price to be
five times the core offer price here's
why
customers are fractal they're 80 20. so
it's the pareto principle right and so
20 of my customers one out of five if i
want to double my revenue i 5x the price
so that one out of five buys my five
times higher price and so i double the
revenue my business by adding a single
upsell
but i might have way higher margins on
my outsole that i have on my original so
i might 2 or 3x or 4x my profit by
having that upsell
down cells so this is an easy one that
[ __ ] no one does um there's two types
of down cells the people that we're
going to say no that then say yes and
the second is people who are going to
leave but then stay all right and so
think about all these as little golden
bb's in the business pro tip for this is
if you're if your sales guys for example
never sell the the low cost things they
get on the phone and the kids like just
you have this thing they never sell it
we do a we do a we buy you lunch it's
the simplest thing in the world we say
who's buying lunch today and so if
anyone sells our low-cost product
because everyone every once in a while
you get an unqualified lead you can't
buy the real thing right and so
whoever sells the the lowest ticket
thing that day the lower ticket thing
the down sell lunch is bought in that
sales guy's honor it worked better than
commissions they were just happy to get
stick you know steak or grub hub every
day and so they just motivate them every
morning to try and get to get lunch
covered for them so a downsell
you have a worse version right you have
one on one you can't really see it here
and then group right version of whatever
the thing you have is the level of
support
you might have a full suite solution and
then you can have a done with you or a
do-it-yourself solution so you have
different levels of service that you're
gonna you're gonna put with it okay and
so let's say in this first example
someone says no and then says yes so
they say no to the core offer so we make
no money
and now we make an extra and here's
what's really cool
the down cells oftentimes for us are
actually higher margin so we sell stuff
that has almost 100 margins for our down
cells so even though we make less
absolute money we still usually do a
pretty decent profit on it right and so
and that's natural because they're going
to be buying something that is lesser
naturally right so you don't want to
give something that's like equal or
still costs you time and money on a down
cell
all right so the second one is uh
instead of getting them to leave we get
them to stay and so we say hey i know
you were at this level support we'll let
you stay for this now
we're going to remove one thing that you
don't care about and so you probably
have more than one service or feature
that you offer remove one
and then give it to them at the lesser
price that way you can ethically say
that you're not charging different rates
for different people so make sense which
of these things catherine do you hate
that you never use this one great knock
it off now you can get it at this price
because especially like software you'll
get a lot better you'll you'll extend
the ltv to the customer
last one cross-sells
everyone talks about these i'll show you
a couple cool things with these that we
do
okay what are all aspects of the
customer journey immediately before and
after purchasing permit what is their
next national need so this is the
question so if you're looking at your
customer journey
what is the thing that they normally do
immediately before they start doing
business with you and what is the thing
that they do immediately after they
start doing business with you after they
purchase there's usually a next natural
thing there's lots of pairings that
happen with with sales right there's
like you you made them make the decision
to do or invest in something right
usually there's other stuff that comes
as a result of that decision we did the
hard work of spending money to acquire
the customer getting on the phone doing
16 follow-up calls to get them to close
then get the rest the [ __ ] money
around them right
and so there's two ways to do this
number one is you can refer the business
out and receive commissions we do this
all the time we've made millions in
commissions just for sending business
that we say hey this is our preferred
partner this is who we recommend and
just like i told you earlier if i'm
sending these guys business they'll send
business back
right and i'll get paid on it so i'm
sending business getting paid and
getting customers as of goodwill does
that make sense yes okay
um number two is that if if it's like a
lot of money that you're referring away
so for example with the gyms we taught
them how to sell supplements
i saw i did the math in my head and i
was like there's a lot of supplements
so let's build that so we decided to
build that right the entire business
ended that's what um alberto is doing
with the mortgages he's doing the bank
now because he's referring that business
out and at a certain point you look at
the math and you're like [ __ ] we should
be owning that right we're sitting these
guys these guys are making more money on
our customers than we are if that's ever
the answer these guys are making more
money than my customers than i am then
that makes sense to do business most
times they're not so i might as well
just take 30 20 40 commission and not
have to deal with a headache but still
get all these little revenue streams
right i'm an affiliate for like 20
different things that we just get paid
for every single month because we would
tell them to do it anyways
so like susie signs up for the gym well
i'm going to tell her well hey they
become affiliates of ours for the
supplements because they refer the
business right but it's like what
apparel grants because they're going to
be like what things my hands are hard
what gloves should i use here's here's
my book of all of my affiliate links
i'll buy them with you together and just
like that we made another 200 on the
customer that took no effort
right so there are these next natural
things that your customers are buying
know what they are and then just provide
them for them ahead of time and get paid
for it so cross sells the simple answer
simple simple example burger
do you want coke with that right it's
different it's not another burger or a
better burger or a faster burger it's a
coke right if i'm selling fitness it's
all fitness would do you want
supplements with that yes right
next version
if i'm selling website design i say hey
now that we have your website do you
want to get advertising with that hey do
you want premium support with that right
these are all next natural needs they're
going to have do you want ads and
premium support and fast cloud service
hosting whatever the you know tech stuff
whatever more of that stuff right all of
these are cross sales that we'll use and
so if you can list out the customer
needs
and think about before and after that's
the easiest way to think about it then
you'll be able to capture all of this
gold in front of you all right and so
this is where a lot of the juice is
squeezed you go from you know you had
500 revenue 250 in gross profit to you
know 520 just by this example right
because you have a ton of extra margin
of these i think i have an example right
here so i don't know if you guys know
this i stole this from digital marketer
you can actually build an entire
business off cross-cells so if your core
product doesn't have
enough juice in it you can actually mark
it down
below the competitors
give it away for free or at a loss call
a loss leader and then
upsell the coke and the fries because
you know that's where all the profit is
right you make the better burger you
sell it at cost or below cost and then
so you said
this is the example you spend a dollar
ninety one to get a person to drive
through earn 18 cents in gross profit
right on the burger but then you make on
the two dollar burger sale but you make
a dollar fourteen on fries and coke
right you're making six times the profit
on the upsell
so if you know these things about your
business and you know that there's an
adjacent thing that's way higher margin
and easier for you that you're usually
just referring it away
well hey make sure you're capturing it
and b if you're not then bring it
in-house
so that was the six i'll do i'll do this
real quick for you so you can see it and
how you make your customers more
valuable and be able to use any
acquisition channel you download please
so that is that is the six of the arms
race of lifetime value there we go check
box worm guy math traffic offer money
those are the four frameworks that we
use to go from a thousand dollars to 112
million in sales in 44 months you guys
good with a quick wrap-up yeah okay
fantastic so i know we covered a lot we
talked about the only way to grow a
business there's only two get more
customers make them worth more right we
talk to the four frameworks we got the
math how to require customers in a
profit the offer how to get complete
strangers to raise their hands and give
you money uh number three how to never
run out of customers because there's
unlimited different pools that you can
go through and then the money how to
become unbeatable on the back end
this is the mass framework that i showed
you guys earlier hopefully this should
now make sense to you in terms of how
you can actually make a profit with zero
dollars up front on acquiring customers
the number one formula that is literally
been the base system which i built my
acquisition life
how it works in a day-to-day basis from
day to day today as you're doing this
process uh the offer itself right the
seven components that i look at uh that
i can kind of boost any of the offers i
have adding guarantees recycling the you
know recycling the naming formula adding
urgency adding scarcity uh making the
core offer smaller adding the bonuses
making sure that the core offers solving
the four main value drivers um seeing if
i can offer free front end or discount
front end so they can attract more
customers
um the value equation itself we can
always use and think back to to make
your core thing more valuable
there's the visuals for those scarcity
urgency guarantees
magic naming formula
the traffic we talked about this the six
different new client sources
the boom if you didn't get that picture
earlier
and then the make them worth more that's
the equation that we use for if you have
a simple business or a recurring
business there's the equations to
calculate it and then you can always
measure against that we now know
how much more powerful pricing is
compared to adding more customers we're
getting them to buy more both those
things are good this is the biggest
lever in your business
so i showed you six ways to make more
money the customer that's the top one
six ways to increase ltgp
increase price reduce cost increase
number of purchases upsells downsides
cross sales
getting down cells you can either get
them to stay longer or just turn to no
into a yes from that all the different
versions of the cross cells that exist
not that you can think of which is
always the next adjacent need
so let me ask you a quick question
let me ask you a slow question
do you feel like you could use any of
these frameworks
yes
do you feel like you understand how to
acquire customers profitably and grow
without capital for those of you who
don't have the capital spent
do you feel like
you could create a more valuable offer
that would get more conversions at
higher prices now
do you feel like you have new client
sources that you have neglected and can
easily use right now
even if you use just a single piece of a
single framework to get you more
customers or make them worth more would
you say our time was well spent
yes
awesome thank you for having
[Applause]